major setback for democrats on capitol
hill what would have been their landmark
voting rights bill
failed 52-48 in the senate last night
with two democrats joining all 50
republicans in opposing a rules change
to push it through the vote came after
hours of passionate speeches from both
sides of the aisle and in a statement
president biden reacted saying quote he
is profoundly disappointed that the
united states senate has failed to stand
up for our democracy close
quote scott mcfarland was inside the
chamber and he joins us now scott this
is a stinging defeat for democrats good
morning hey tony good morning supporters
said this voting rights law would have
made it easier to vote and stop
suppression at the ballot box critics
said it was a power grab to rewrite the
rule books but in the end it was senate
democrats here at the capitol who
couldn't wrangle enough votes to make it
law
on this vote the age of 52 the nays
are 48. president biden's landmark
voting legislation failed in the senate
late wednesday night this is a moral
moment
in america
after nearly 12 hours of heated debate
over changing filibuster rules to get
the bill through they would shatter the
soul of the senate for short-term power
this is an unprecedented coordinated
attack to make voting harder for
eligible citizens facing a wall of
unanimous republican opposition
democrats were dealt back-to-back losses
without being able to change senate
procedures eliminate the filibuster and
pass sweeping voting rights law one of
the holdouts west virginia's joe manchin
eliminating the filibuster would be the
easy way out
it wasn't meant to be easy the proposed
voting legislation would have allowed
for early voting and no excuse mail in
voting nationwide and it would have made
election day a federal holiday two of
the senate's three black members clashed
over accusations that any opposition was
an attempt to deny minorities the vote i
felt frustration and irritation
rising in my souls as i
keep hearing the references
to jim crow i asked myself how many
americans
understand what jim crow
was
don't lecture me
about jim crow
i know this is not 1965.
that's what makes me so outraged
it's 2022
and they're blatantly removing more
polling places
from the counties where black and
latinos
are overrepresented members of the
congressional black caucus took a
last-minute stand outside the senate but
walked away knowing the voting rights
law was set to fail
joe manchin that pivotal senator from
west virginia said yesterday he's open
to changing the electoral college count
act the law by which congress counts the
electoral votes after a presidential
election that was the process
interrupted by the capital attack
january 6th but the outlook for that is
cloudy democrats have been emphatic they
want much bigger change gail
right cloudy normally never a good thing
thank you very much scott